sustainable
eco-conscious made from recycled
materials companies are using phrases
like these more and more frequently
today sales of consumer packaged Goods
advertising sustainability in North
America Rose by over 30 percent in just
five years reaching an estimated
268.9 billion dollars in 2022 and more
than 60 percent of consumers say they'd
pay more for a product with sustainable
packaging but underneath the flashy
buzzwords companies can fall short of
their eco-friendly promises
environmental activists say an ongoing
legal battle with h m might highlight a
big company's alleged greenwashing
that's when companies mislead consumers
with Promises of being more eco-friendly
than they actually are
in 2022 a class action lawsuit claimed
that the clothing retailers conscious
Choice collection advertised itself is
sustainable but it was actually not made
from sustainable and environmentally
friendly materials
the case is still ongoing and H M says
it's taking these allegations very
seriously is looking into them
thoroughly and that its sustainability
work has never been about greenwashing
here's how a lack of transparency with
consumers long timelines and weak
environmental goals can all be signals
of greenwashing
green washing is when a company or
organization uses misleading advertising
to Market itself as more environmentally
friendly than it really is sustainable
ESG funds or Investments That consider
environmental social and corporate
governance factors have exploded over
the past decade exceeding 350 billion
dollars in net Assets in 2021 it's
becoming increasingly profitable for
companies to be seen as being beneficial
to the environment consumers are
increasingly demanding sustainable
products investors want to invest in
companies that have lower carbon
Footprints so why do people criticize
greenwashing when you buy from a company
that is engaging in green washing
practices you are encouraging that
behavior to continue other companies
will take note some companies say their
sustainability efforts are better than
doing nothing but critics would argue
brainwashing involves weak goals lack of
transparency with consumers and long
timeline
take one common corporate environmental
promise reducing carbon emissions One
Way companies say they reduce their
emissions is by purchasing carbon
offsets a carbon offset is an action or
activity that balances the emission of
carbon dioxide or other greenhouse gases
into the atmosphere it's a viable
sellable and tradable commodity in
theory when a company buys a carbon
offset it finances an action that
removes greenhouse gas emissions from
the air like planting trees or building
renewable energy projects this is
supposed to balance the overall amount
of carbon dioxide a company puts into
the atmosphere carbon offsets and carbon
credits have become an incredibly
controversial mechanism in the fight
against climate change and activists and
environmentalists claim and our
reporting shows many of these projects
are generating credits too many credits
and not really reducing or removing
emissions that companies are paying for
critics say carbon offset goals are weak
and that companies aren't transparent
with consumers about how they'll achieve
them while companies can claim they're
putting money towards carbon offsets the
offset's environmental impact isn't
always clear to Consumers Plus activists
say companies have decades-long
timelines to reach their goals a company
can promise to achieve zero emissions by
2050 but if it doesn't have intermediary
goals it's unclear when it will actually
start reducing emissions and time is
essential for reducing greenhouse gas
emissions that's because the United
Nations Paris agreement calls for Global
emissions to be reduced by 45 percent by
2030. in order to keep global
temperatures from Rising by no more than
1.5 degrees Celsius so who is policing
greenwashing companies when a company
does engage in green washing the
negative outcomes for them are quite
Limited in the worst case it might be a
fine at this point in 2022 Goldman
sachs's asset man judgment arm paid
Millions after violating SEC compliance
rules with ESG fund marketing Goldman
neither admitted nor denied the sec's
allegations but there's increased
efforts by governments to start cracking
down on greenwashing companies in March
the European Union ruled out a series of
proposals which would require companies
to back up their products environmental
claims with scientific evidence these
claims would then need to be
independently verified this is part of a
larger effort to make it easier for
consumers to choose sustainable products
there are roughly 450 million people in
the European Union regulations adopted
there often lead to larger changes
globally since multinational companies
prefer not to work with different sets
of rules around the world and there's
movement in the us as well
the Federal Trade Commission is
discussing rules that would regulate
environmental marketing claims it also
wants to penalize companies for each
time a product uses deceptive language
and the SEC is proposing new disclosure
and naming and requirements for ESG
funds